let's get some insight now from senior
presidential advisor jared kushner jared
thanks for the time
i want to talk about this big peace deal
between israel and the uae we heard the
president talking about it i wonder if
you could kind of lift the veil
about how we as a country got here sure
well thank you brad it's great to be
with you today and
you know being in washington there are a
lot of days where you see a lot of
process
you see a lot of posturing but it's very
rare that you have a day where you can
truly celebrate a historic achievement
that will
really change the course of a region and
the world this is something the
president really started on on his first
foreign trip we went to
saudi arabia in may of 2017. i believe
you were there actually
and uh at that speech the president laid
out a new vision for the region
since then president trump has taken
back the territorial caliphate
of isis he's killed several of the
terrorist leaders
he's brought all the people in the
region together and he's worked very
closely with
israel and with other arab countries to
align them around
shared interests and and also to make
sure that they can together
uh combat common threats so this was a
very intense uh set of diplomacy it's
taken three and a half years but
president trump now
has really set the stage in the middle
east to accomplish this historic
breakthrough but many many more great
things that i believe can happen
in the months and years ahead yeah he
suggested that there may be other
countries coming on board
are there we have a lot of interest from
a lot of countries you know people
are often afraid to go first i think a
lot of countries are watching to see how
this plays out
so far it's been very positively
received in the country and a lot of
these people
they don't want to focus on past
conflicts they want to focus on
how they can have a better future they
want their children to lead better lives
than them they want security
they want economic economic prosperity
and if you look at the united arab
emirates and you look at israel they're
both technology powerhouses financial
powerhouses
and most importantly security
powerhouses so this really is a great
alignment and again president
trump uh built trust after the last
administration both parties had
uh felt uh down on their relationship
with america they felt very very
betrayed after
uh the iran deal which sent 150 billion
dollars to iran and they
used that money to fund a lot of the
proxies that were destabilizing the
region
but president trump has rebuilt that
trust he's brought them closer together
and he's aligned them around a common
vision that could be good and i will say
this too you know somebody said to me
very early on when i got this
assignment they said you don't lose
money betting against success in the
middle east but
i also say you can lose a lot of money
betting against trump and
president trump took on this challenge
he wasn't afraid to fail
he tried doing it in an unconventional
way and by doing it he's achieved a
truly historic result well i want to uh
i want to ask you another question about
this and first i want to
let you listen to prime minister
netanyahu and his comments late this
afternoon sure
this is the greatest advancements toward
peace between israel
and the arab world in the last 26 years
this is a future of peace
a future of security and the future of
prosperity
when did the prime minister finally
agree to hold off on annexation
and do you have a sense of how long this
pause is going to be
so we've been speaking about what
annexation would look like for the last
six months you know you know the prime
minister
really is a historic leader he's a
visionary he's
uh he he was able to agree to a
two-state solution
with the palestinians on the basis of
president trump's vision for peace and
to
have the first time we ever had a map
forward so we were talking about how we
could implement this plan
because by implementing the plan we'd
actually be saving the two-state
solution
not destroying it which would be a
massive change so we've been talking
about it for a bunch of
uh months and then obviously over the
last six weeks the notion
of a normalization in lieu of a uh of
applying israeli sovereignty came
up and uh prime minister netanyahu did
the calculus and saw that
this was much more in the interests of
israel in the short medium and long term
and
that's what great leaders do they put
the politics aside and they make the
right decisions
that strengthen their countries and keep
their people safe all right i want to
turn to the election
you're deeply involved you were last
time you're this time
uh you just heard our new fox news poll
uh with
uh vice president former vice president
biden leading by seven points in that
poll
but in the job performance uh the
president is at 44
disapproved 54 percent uh and and in who
is trusted to do a better job uh on
different issues
uh the president is up three on the
economy but he is losing to vice
president biden on a number of
key issues where do you see this race
right now so
we've spoken about the methodology of
the fox polls and
we saw in the last election out of 120
polls conducted in michigan wisconsin
and pennsylvania
between labor day and the election out
of 120 only one showed
president trump ahead so uh this these
polls are based off of flawed
methodology
uh our polls basically show that the
president is leading in a lot of the
states that he won last time
and we were just in ohio and our team we
won the president won ohio by eight and
a half points
he believes he's going to win by more
this time and if you go state by state
and you look at real voter turnout
models
you look at the enthusiasm we're seeing
very very encouraging signs on the
ground and
we think the people of this country love
what president trump's doing and they
want to see him back
in the in office for four more years so
that he can
continue to rebuild the economy and
finish the job that he started just to
be clear when you say flawed you'd like
to see likely voters not registered
voters you'd like to see a small the
sample that matches how you see the
election shaping up but if you look at
the real clear politics average
uh joe biden is up seven and a half
points it's an average of recent polls
across the board
and the average of battlegrounds you can
see biden with the lead
i get that you don't like polls at this
point and you like them to be likely
no but what i would just say is look on
election day last year everyone thought
it was going to be a landslide i was
looking at our data and our show that
trump
data showed that trump was going to win
the landslide a lot of those polls are
using a 24
republican turnout model but in 2018 and
2016
it was 33 so i don't know why the
companies are spending money
on these polls because it's not
scientific and it's not indicative of
what's actually going to happen but
that's another story yeah well we can
talk about poll
methodology and as we get closer we'll
get a different
mindset as we look at those i want to
ask you the president addressed these
questions about
the post office and about funding the
post office spent a lot of time in that
briefing
the critics are saying that after his
interview with maria bartoromo today
that he's essentially brazenly
attempting to
what they say is steal the election by
invalidating vote by mail ballots
or that he's deliberately damaging the
post office to somehow
change the election address that from
that charge
that the critics are giving yeah one of
the presidents trump's many skills is
that he gets his critics to go crazy on
all types of things and end up making
his point
all president trump's been trying to say
is that uh there are some states that
have been doing mail-in ballots in
different forms whether it's absentee
ballot
and they do it appropriately if you're
trying to rush a whole system all the
recent examples are showing
that it just doesn't work it's not
seamless it's like saying we're trusting
the post office to be the most efficient
arbiter of our democracy
i don't think anyone thinks that that's
the case so president trump is trying to
bring
attention to an issue and it is a big
issue we saw that in new york we've seen
that in various states
and president trump just wants a fair
and well-run election and he's working
hard to make sure that that happens
all right another thing that's setting
off the critics is you and ivanka
meeting with kanye west in colorado
you said you've been friends however he
is running for president there are
charges that
uh that this is a coordinated plan to
somehow siphon black votes away from
from joe biden how do you respond to
that yeah look
unlike others i'm able to keep
friendships across the aisle and
and kanye's been a friend for 10 years
he's a very very special person
he's a very successful music artist he's
a very successful designer he's been
very successful a lot of the things he's
done
we were together in the same spot kanye
sent me a book
about a month ago called powernomics by
dr claude anderson i read the book it
was absolutely phenomenal it actually
incorporated a lot of the things that
president trump has been doing and it's
something i've distributed more copies
to my domestic policy team because i
think there's a lot of inspiration we
can get from it
for president trump's second term agenda
so we were more talking about ideas and
uh again friendships uh should trump
politics and uh
that's what's most do you know that are
the charges that republican operatives
are trying to help him get on these
ballots
is that true do you know that again we
we did not discuss his uh his campaign
and
uh and i'm what he's up to i read things
in the press but
i have not discussed that directly with
him okay and you don't know that that's
happening
uh look like i've said i've learned in
five years of doing this now that
uh just because something's said in the
media doesn't mean it's true so i'd like
to investigate the facts look at the
real data
and unless i feel like something's
verified i tend not to
assume that it's it's gospel all right
two more things really quickly who's
really in charge of the campaign
there's some who think that you are
still the de facto campaign manager
uh president trump has always been in
charge of the campaign and he always
will be in charge of the campaign and
my job is to help him make sure that he
has good options for people good people
around him
and people who can execute and right now
we have over 1500 people in the field
we've got over a million and a half
volunteers
we've got a tremendous organization the
online fundraising has been tremendous
and so president trump has a very very
strong operation but that's because of
his leadership
and his vision he sets the message he
sets the tone he decides where he wants
to go
and he's got a lot of people like myself
who help him execute that
you know uh very last thing you said he
likes to stir up his critics
at that press briefing he seemed to give
credence to a newsweek
op-ed that questioned the eligibility of
kamala harris
uh being able to run for vice president
why why do that i'll be honest brett
i've been out here waiting to do your
show so i haven't seen that i haven't
seen the op-ed so
i'll reserve judgment on that until i
know more about it okay
she was born in oakland california the
indian and jamaican immigrants
on california soil she's natural born
citizen anyway
if you see this election are you losing
right now
or do you see that you have to make up
ground
before november 3rd how do you see it
playing out over 82 days
right so i think that president trump is
in a much better position now in this
campaign than he was going into the last
campaign
again he's been an underdog all of his
life but he always comes through take
today's
peace deal for instance uh nobody
thought that we'd be able to do anything
like this
and again it shows that president
trump's style is that
he does things in untraditional ways he
makes people uncomfortable
he he takes different approaches maybe
he uses people who would people wouldn't
think would be the normal people to do
it
but at the end of the day he gets
results and that's what really matters
and the american people
they like results and and they want
results from their leaders and i think
they're tired of politicians who
who talk and talk and talk what
president trump has brought to
washington
is accountability he's brought action
he's very transparent think about it
with president trump on
any issue you don't have to wonder what
his policy is on anything you don't have
to worry what he's thinking
just look at twitter look at his press
conferences he's the most accessible
president
and so people really know what they're
going to get with president trump and i
do think that america is with his
policies and they want to see
him be the person that's going to
rebuild the country after the
coronavirus and keep doing the great
policies
that he's been doing but again today's
historic agreement between israel and
uae
would not have been possible without
president trump's leadership uh the
trust that he's built with our allies
and
the middle east is a much safer place
than when president trump came into
office four years ago
well there's no doubt there's a big
foreign policy win we started with that
thanks for taking all of our questions
and for the time great great to be with
you brad
jared kushner